[Music]
Ruby starts with Toni's press conference
from the end of the first movie but it's
different in several spots a suit that
conveniently appeared despite the fact
that you sort they despise bodyguards
yes what news conference would cut away
to a shot of all the reporters listening
to Tony Stark during the middle of it
all so don't quite remember there being
a camera pointed away from Tony during
the press conference
Mickey Rourke looks older than the guy
playing his sick and dying dad go
toe-to-toe on subpar days I'm actually
quite beatable Tony changes clothes
between the stage and backstage
a hush went over the crowd at Rody's
alarming weight loss in substantial
plastic surgery work since his last
public appearance
I believe that's North Korea see
Transformers Iron Man knows what kind of
threat North Korea is the c-span YouTube
channel misspelled the word capital in
the title of the video also 1.8 million
views but only 10 ratings that's clearly
a case of someone buying views right
that view count is totally artificially
inflated there's only about 8,000 and 11
things that I really need to talk damn
if she only had 990 more it would be
nice Stark's mirror image doesn't match
the real Starks movements I'm pretty
sure that the Monaco Grand Prix track
officials would not allow him to drive
this car for any reason despite Tony
being in love with her and her being the
CEO and you know a woman happy still
inexplicably takes pepper with him on
his car trips straight to where the
fighting is happening this is a pretty
suicidal way to bring Tony a suit you
know these guys are driving 220 miles
per hour in the opposite direction right
also once a guy gets on the track
throwing around lightning whips don't
you think these drivers would be told to
stop the race so wait Ivan's plan was to
use his whips at the Monaco Grand Prix
because he somehow knew Tony Stark was
gonna replace his driver at the last
minute Ranko can hit its target when
it's a race car going 200 miles an hour
but not when his targets are stationary
and right in front of him it's also nice
of Benko to wait patiently and not kill
anyone with its whip while this portable
Iron Man suit takes several seconds to
attach itself to start oh good glad the
CRS crew is here now
wait couldn't one of them have shot this
guy sooner you could double up your
rotations focused the repulsor energy
plasma channels it's effective sure just
tell the bad guy how to kill you better
next time why isn't this guard already
trying to beat Ivan to a pulp right now
for not being in his cell
I guess no one will ask questions about
where this prisoner went and why there
was a dead guard in the middle of the
jail when they wrap up the case of
Ivan's mysterious death why didn't the
dirty guards let I even know what the
plan was before he started stupidly
walking around the jail with no clue is
Jarvis assisting both of these guys or
just stark who does Rhodey talk to
inside his suit two metal men in a
boxing ring and not one Rock'em Sock'em
robots reference I mean the filmmakers
aren't taking this movie seriously so
how they missed that Howard Stark is a
madman there's a little bit of Roger
Sterling in this guy I wonder if Howard
Stark was also banging Joan okay I'm
done no more people are relying on you
to be Iron Man and you disappeared
couldn't have said it better myself we
came to see Iron Man and what we get is
too short action scenes one big finale
and tons of masturbatory Avengers
references there for almost 20 years
well you said earlier he was cold and
distant and didn't have time for you so
I doubt he was ever schooling you unless
you mean literally taking you to school
isn't talking about a guy whose happiest
day was when he shipped me off to
boarding school why does this beam of
unexplained makeup burn through concrete
and steel but not the cables just to the
left of this triangle holding thing why
does Vanko keep zipping and unzipping
his switcher throughout this scene Tony
mutes the call with Vanko so he can talk
to jarvis without Vanko hearing but then
carries on talking to both of them
without using the mute button anymore
sure dad assemble the suit while you're
at it together in the first movie it
took five hours for a suit to be
assembled even if Tony has gotten much
more efficient the second movie makes it
feel like he can just print out suits in
mere minutes movie shrugs its shoulders
about all the people who surely died
from falling shards of glass
target on what Goodin roads just have
said my suit is target locked on you
without being coy no one gets hurt or
killed when the world-class ammunition
breaks through the observatory tower
glass this drone manages to crash land
without hitting one person in a large
crowd of people iron man takes a
sweet-ass time saving this kid who might
be blown to bits any second why would
banco take control of roadies suit but
still even able to talk to stark on the
comm you're just now thinking of this
car does not include driver's side lap
dance drone 303 you shot down here and
then the tracking system indicates it's
actually here that it gets shot down and
oh yeah drone 305 was destroyed at some
point - how was this guy planning to
attack Natasha was he hoping to catch
her by surprise by hiding in this closed
doorway and plain view how was Romanoff
able to read Starks vitals from bancos
computer even though Tony says the
drones will arrive any second he and
roads still waste 15 seconds bickering
about who should stand where why doesn't
Vanko just have all the drones fire all
the missiles as soon as they land
instead of dramatically pausing for
several 10 seconds
couldn't Tony just have done this in the
first place no I think you should lead
with that next time yeah no I don't want
it's a one-off yeah that's funny Tony
that was the one time to use it face
when you surrounded
okay so the first Iron Man movie had
some bad guy making his own Iron Man
suit and then the climax is a big Iron
Man versus Iron Man thing the second
movie has a bad guy making his own Iron
Man suit and then the climax is a big
Iron Man versus an Iron Man Thing if the
Mandarin has his own Iron Man suit and
Iron Man 3 they'll have the trifecta
okay so any sensible person would have
taken off flying the very second bancos
chess piece started blinking red but
instead Iron Man and Robi have two pawns
and then have a chat about it
also a Vanko so smartest to set up a
fail-safe measure in the self-destruct
thing and why is he so dumb as to set
him on a 30-second delay giving Tony and
Rhodes plenty of time to get away
look I know the last time Tony saw
pepper was right here and then the
building is evacuated and then she tells
this cop she's gonna stay but Tony
doesn't know that so how does he know to
fly to this exact place to save her at
the last minute I heard though you
should get lost I was here first I was
here first heard the whole thing this is
a random roof in the middle of Queens
what made you go here of all places
[Music]
you want a burglar in my port engine
where you Stenberg I bump my book are we
talking about is this a burden back in
Russia we get you the bird now this is
my book what do you mean that's the bird
this is the bird yeah well us won't get
this bird we got this there's a great
bird focus my foot but if it's not the
bird I mean this is it this is a
gorgeous bird I liked you I got you the
bird
hey there is bird man I know you like
the bird is that your bird you love that
furikake you know what take the bird
[Music]
simple stuff how's that make you feel